I'm holding you in contempt of court
there's a surprise what'd you say what'd
you just say don't talk back to the
judge quit while you're ahead
or quit well you're slightly behind this
movie is so great
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer all right animated smile more
today we are covering my cousin Vinnie
one of my favorite legal movies of all
time and if there is one question I get
more than any other it is what do you
win don't you know again if there is one
comment that I get more than any other
its whether my cousin Vinnie is in fact
legally accurate it's certainly a
favorite among lawyers we quote this
movie all the time
what are the Ute so be sure to comment
in the form of an objection which will
either sustain or overrule and stick
around until the end of the video where
I give my cousin Vinnie a grade for
legal realism so without further ado
let's dig in to my cousin Vinnie what
are we gonna do now probably nothing
alright it might be a tear light or
something just relax we don't have any
money for bail hey we don't need money
for bail nothing's happened now I think
we're getting pulled over aren't we use
the old something oh I forgot some
background here that actually helps
explain the rest of this movie the movie
starts with two kids from New York who
are driving it through the south they
stopped at a grocery store called the
sac-o-suds to pick up some supplies and
they accidentally leave with a can of
tuna in their pocket without paying for
it they think that when the police
pulled them over they're being pulled
over for accidentally shoplifting a can
of tuna when in fact the store manager
was murdered just after they left the
store okay so with that background that
will make the rest of this movie make a
lot more sense
show me your hands Jesus show me your
hands get him up get him up up now put
your hands on top of your head and get
out of the car out of the car all right
so this is a case of mistaken identity
but it's important to note that when a
policeman stops your car it's generally
considered a seizure for Fourth
Amendment purposes so generally speaking
the police may not stop your car unless
they have at least reasonable suspicion
to believe that the law has been
violated provided that the police have
lawfully stopped the vehicle the officer
can order the occupants to get out in
the name of officer safety here all of
those requirements are met we have a
murder that was conducted by people
driving a very similar car who fit the
description of the defendants here so
it's very likely that the police did in
fact have probable cause to stop this
car and were correct in ordering the
occupants to get out of the car because
of the grisly nature of the murder that
just happened nearby ridiculous also for
a can of tuna okay so that was a classic
police lineup there are a couple
problems here a defendant can attack the
identification as denying due process
when the identification the lineup
itself is unnecessarily suggestive and
there is a substantial likelihood of
misidentification if we roll the clip
back we can see that the two defendants
here look nothing like the rest of the
people in the lineup they are several
feet shorter and far skinnier also
additionally both of them are in the
lineup at the same tunning and that is
likely to be unnecessarily suggestive
and to create a false positive which is
exactly what happened here
well approve no attorney from out of
state is not but in formal manner I just
have a few questions yeah cool this is a
real thing it's a motion called a pro
Hawk Beach a motion where an
out-of-state attorney wants to have
temporary permission to practice in a
state that they aren't licensed usually
you have to be sponsored by another
attorney but you always have to vouch
and say that you are going to follow the
laws of that state and jurisdiction when
you apply how long you been practicing
about six almost 16 years that's quite a
few moves out come you know win some
lose some
never a good idea to lie to a judge the
judge will find out eventually and you
can be sanctioned both in the state that
you are trying to get into but also the
state that you come from as well mr.
Gambini stand up not again not tell you
next time you appear in my courtroom
that you dress appropriately you were
serious about that again where an actual
suit and tie when you go to court I
really wish I could tell Joe Pesci where
I get all of my suits from Chino prata
Styles all of them good stole is fires
burn steal his files listen to this I'm
just ready to finesse him I'm starting a
finessing right I got him gone he offers
to have his secretary copy everything
from me that's very impressive finessing
yeah in reality the reason that the
prosecution would turn over materials to
the defenses they have a constitutional
obligation to do so the government has a
duty to disclose material certainly all
exculpatory evidence but generally that
translates to all of the material that
the prosecution has under Supreme Court
precedents specifically the 1963 case of
Brady versus Maryland failure to
disclose that evidence whether willful
or inadvertent is a due process
violation so the prosecutor here was
constitutionally obligated to turn over
his files to Joe Pesci had nothing to do
with his smoothing and to not do so
would be what's called a Brady violation
and could have resulted in overturning
the conviction if he was able to get a
conviction just wonder why try to gave
his files I told you why away he has to
by law you're entitled it's called
disclosure in hey I just said that nice
job Marissa
he has to show you everything otherwise
it could be a mistrial he has to give
you a list of all those witnesses you
can talk to all his witnesses he's not
allowed any surprises yep
gone are the days of trying to ambush
either party at trial prosecution has to
turn over not only their evidence but as
part of the pre-trial filings you have
to disclose who the witnesses are that
you're going to rely on so that no one
is sandbagged when they actually get to
trial that doesn't help anyone didn't
teach you that in law school either
guess not
are you mocking me with that outfit
mocking you no I'm not mocking you judge
then explain that outfit I bought a suit
you've seen it now it's covered in mud
this town doesn't have a one-hour
cleaners so I had to buy a new suit
except that the only store you could buy
a new suit in has got the flu
hit that the whole store got the flu so
I had to get this in a secondhand store
Joe Pesci could really use a place where
he could get affordable custom-made suit
so he could actually have more than one
suit when he shows up to court for a
capital murder case
indogene I think you made your point
in all seriousness he probably would
have been better off wearing his actual
normal suit covered in mud I've actually
known lawyers who will purposefully
scuff up their suits so that they seem
more approachable by the jury you on
drugs drugs no I don't take drugs I
don't like your attitude I'm holding you
in contempt of court here's a surprise
what'd you say what what'd you just say
don't talk back to the judge quit while
you're ahead
or quit well you're slightly behind this
movie is so great Council members of the
jury the evidence in this case is gonna
show that at 9:30 in the morning of
January 4th both defendants Stanley
rothenstein and William Gambini were
seen getting out of there
metallic green 1964 Buick Skylark
convertible with a white top the
evidence is going to show that they were
seen entering the sac-o-suds convenience
store in Wazzu City the evidence is
going to show that minutes after they
entered the sac-o-suds a gunshot was
heard by three our witnesses you go then
hear the testimony of the three
eyewitnesses who saw the defendants
running out of the sac-o-suds a moment
after the shots were heard getting into
their faded metallic green 1964 Buick
Skylark and driving off in great haste
all right
I really really really like the
prosecutors opening statement in this
movie there are a couple things that
he's doing that actually rarely happened
correctly in the movies number one this
prosecutor is giving a short summary of
what the evidence will show opening
statements are about essentially priming
the jury for the story that is going to
be elicited through the evidence and
through the witnesses so this
prosecutors doing a fantastic job of
explaining what the evidence will show
on top of that this prosecutor is doing
a great job of using the space in front
of the jury while also at the same time
maintaining a respectful distance away
from the jury box if you enter the well
and go straight to the area right in
front of the jury the judge is going to
have a huge problem with that but I like
that he starts a counsel table talks
about what the evidence is going to show
and specifically to highlight the
testimony of a specific witness he then
walks over towards the witness stand and
gestures to where the testimony is going
to come from so he is being dramatic in
somewhat theatrical but within the
bounds of what someone would actually do
in a way that makes rhetorical sense
counselor you wish to make an open
statement I have never seen lead trial
counsel fall asleep at counsel table but
I have 100% seen other attorneys who are
at counsel table fall asleep I've seen
members of the jury fall asleep during
the trial I've seen people in the
gallery fall asleep
at trial I've actually seen a bailiff
fall asleep in a trial once a lot of the
trial process is actually pretty boring
and mundane and it's not uncommon to see
people fall asleep just not the head
trial counsel everything that guy just
says thank you
in addition to being vulgar and
disrespectful to the court that's
technically an argument and not allowed
as your opening statement mr. Tipton
when you viewed the defendants walking
from their car into the sac-o-suds what
angle was your point of view they was
kind of walking toward me when they
entered the stone and when they left
what angle was your point of view it was
kind of walking away from me so would
you say you got a better shot at I'm
going in and not so much coming out you
could say that I did say that would you
say that yeah this is really good the
testimony was ambiguous and so Joe Pesci
here follows up and confirms that the
witness does in fact agree with the
statement that Joe Pesci has said that
is a very crucial thing that a lot of
lawyers miss it's so easy when you're in
the heat of cross-examination that you
just assume that the testimony is what
you think it is when in reality we're
really unreliable narrators so it's a
great idea to make sure and summarize
and get the witness to actually state
exactly what it is you want them to
prove and on top of that when you're
getting good testimony it's a great idea
to get the witness to repeat the thing
that is actually good for you so great
job by Joe Pesci here so far is it
possible to to use to what oh what was
that word to what what did you say Utes
yeah to Utes what are the ute excuse me
to use that's great because again in the
heat or cross-examination sometimes
people slur their words sometimes the
court report
can't take down exactly what was head
where people kind of talk over each
other so it is a real thing where the
judge or particularly the stenographer
will actually stop the testimony to
clarify and of course this is probably
the most classic scene in the entire
movie and it's just hilarious because
there's a kernel truth in it is it
possible the two defendants entered the
store picked 22 specific items off of
the shelves had the clerk take money
make change
then leave then two different men drive
up in a similar don't shake it I'm not
done yet with the eight old things so
you can understand this now two
different men drive up in a
similar-looking car go in shoot the
clerk robbed him and then leave no they
didn't have enough time well how much
time was they in the store five minutes
five minutes are you sure did you look
at your watch oh I'm sorry you testified
earlier that the boys went into the
store and you had just begun to make
breakfast you were just ready to eat you
heard a gunshot that's right I'm sorry
so obviously it takes you five minutes
to make breakfast that's right all right
so you knew that do you remember what
you had eggs and grits so Joe Pesci is
being a little bit argumentative here
but what he's doing is he is setting a
factual and logical trap for the witness
to show that the witness doesn't have
the kind of veracity or truthfulness
that would be necessary to convict for
beyond a reasonable doubt if you can
show that a witness is lying or can't be
trusted on one thing members of the jury
are far less likely to believe them on
most of the rest of their testimony that
can be really really important for
disproving the testimony of an
eyewitness instant grits no
self-respecting southerner uses instant
grits
I think proud of my grits so mr. Tipton
how could it take you five minutes to
cook your grits when it takes the entire
grit eating world 20 minutes so it's a
great question because there's no good
answer for the witness and additionally
it relies on facts not in evidence that
it's actually take 20 minutes in real
life he would have had to have this
witness established that grits take 20
minutes to cook so you got to be really
really careful when you're doing a
tactic like what Joe Pesci is doing and
it can work out but it's very very
dangerous on cross because you don't
know which way it's gonna go what these
pictures of my house and stuff house and
stuff and what is this brown stuff and
the windows mmm dirt dirt what is this
rusty dusty dirty looking thing over
your window it's a screen a screen it's
a screen and what are these really big
things right in the middle of your view
from the window of your kitchen to the
sac-o-suds what do we call these big
things Therese I absolutely love what
Joe Pesci is doing right here he is
using effectively incontrovertible
evidence no one's gonna dispute what
these things are in the photos but he is
walking the witness down a logical path
that he's not going to be able to get
out of which is that there's a lot of
stuff between his vantage point and the
events that he is an eyewitness to this
is one of the reasons why direct
evidence through eyewitness testimony
can be actually very very unreliable but
what Joe Pesci is doing is he is just
having the witness agree to just these
tiny little facts and there's no way to
dispute all of the little bread crumbs
he's getting on his trail to get to the
ultimate conclusion that his eyewitness
testimony is not really that believable
so the questions are fantastic the only
thing I would have liked to have seen is
a projector or an Elmo that displays
these photos in blow-up so that the jury
can also see exactly what it is that the
witness is referring to you could
positively identify the defendants for a
moment of two seconds looking true this
dirty window this crud covers
Green these trees with all these leaves
on them and I don't know how many bushes
was like five hey don't forget this one
in this one seven bushes seven bushes so
what do you think is it possible you
just saw two guys in a green convertible
and not necessarily these two particular
guys I suppose and what you see here is
that the answer that the witness
provides it doesn't matter the witness
here can agree or the witness cannot
agree but the sign of a good cross is
that you don't actually care what the
witness is going to say in fact if he
had said that it was a perfect
identification he would have lost
credibility based on all of the things
that Joe Pesci just talked about here so
that is the sign of a masterful
cross-examination I would recommend all
lawyers watch this particular
cross-examination of this witness is the
best so far on the special automotive
instructor of forensic studies for the
Federal Bureau investigation uh-huh how
long you been in that position 18 years
Your Honor may we approach the bench
please if you wish my objective this
witness being called at this time we've
been given no prior notice he testified
no discovery of any test he's conducted
a report he's prepared and as the court
is aware the defense is entitled to
advance notice of any witness who
testified particularly those who would
give scientific evidence so that we
could properly prepare for
cross-examination as well as to give the
defense an opportunity to have the
witnesses reports reviewed by a defense
expert who might then be in a position
to contradict the veracity of his
conclusions the prosecution here has
made a huge mistake which is they
haven't laid the foundation for how this
guy is a credible expert who can testify
in court so there's really only two
kinds of witnesses there are language
nurses who can only testify to things
they actually perceive and then there
are experts who are allowed to testify
to there
pinions on things based on the evidence
presented to them and under Rule 702 of
the rules of procedure the expert has to
have scientific technical or specialized
knowledge that will help the Trier of
fact the testimony has to be based on
sufficient facts or data the testimony
has to be the product of reliable
principles and methods and the expert
has to have reliably applied the
principles and methods to the case at
hand so on top of fre 702 you also have
to meet these Dalbert standard which is
meant to give the court the gatekeeping
function to prevent junk science from
getting into the court there is no way
that these tire marks were made by 64
buick skylark these marks were made by a
1963 Pontiac Tempest objection your
honor can we clarify to the court
whether the witness is stating opinion
or fact this is your opinion it's a fact
I find it it's actually opinion that
this kind of information could be
ascertained simply by looking at a
picture would you like me to explain to
you this these two equal length tire
marks had positraction can't make those
marks without positraction which was not
available on the 64 buick skylark and
why not what is positraction it's a
limited slip differential which
distributes power equally to both the
right and left tires the 64 Skylark had
a regular differential which anyone has
been stuck in the mud and Alabama knows
you step on the gas one tire spins the
other side does not been so good a great
direct examination by Joe Pesci and
great testimony by Marissa Tomei
unlike in cross-examination where the
attorney is the star and the witness's
answers are almost irrelevant it's the
absolute opposite on direct examination
there you want all eyes on the witness
and all you're doing is asking questions
that allow the witness to expand and
you're softly guiding where you want the
witness to go Joe Pesci's questions are
fantastic essentially what happened next
or can you explain why that is what is
that technical term that you
excuse he's using great open-ended
questions he's not leading her anywhere
and he is letting the witness be the
star now in the 60s there were only two
other cars made in America that had
positraction and independent rear
suspension and enough power to make
these marks one was the Corvette which
could never be confused with the Buick
Skylark the other had the same body
length
height width weight wheelbase and wheel
track as the 64 Skylark and that was the
1963 Pontiac Tempest and because both
cars were made by GM were both cars
available in metallic mint-green paint
hey whoa
thank you miss Vito no more questions
thank you very very much
you've been a lovely lovely witness it's
probably not appropriate but God it's a
perfect scene how can you just not love
that direct examination and Marisa Tomei
is expert opinion fantastic amazing okay
that was my cousin Vinnie now it's time
to give the movie a grade for legal
realism I have a soft spot in my heart
for this movie it's so good everyone
should absolutely see it if you've never
seen it before I hope it didn't ruin it
first of all you have Joe Pesci giving a
masterful cross-examination and a
masterful direct examination that
frankly you could take those clips and
use them to teach trial advocacy in law
school you have some motion practice and
some Civil Procedure that is not a
hundred percent accurate but pretty
close of course as a comedy they take
license with a few things Joe Pesci is
floundering around making huge mistakes
but it sort of fits the narrative
because he's supposed to be a really
terrible attorney who just got out of
law school at the beginning of this
movie and there's some shenanigans with
experts being allowed when they
shouldn't be in lying to the judge but
it's done in such a way that it has a
grain of truth to it so it's hard for me
to get over just how good this movie is
because it's a fantastic comedy it's a
good
and it's a nice work of legal fiction so
I don't see how I can give my cousin
Vinnie anything less than an A it's so
good go watch this movie the defense
rests
Vincent Gambini really screwed up by not
wearing a proper suit to court it's hard
to overstate the value of a great suit
all of my suits are now custom made by
indogene oh I buy them with my own money
I love their stuff so much I personally
reached out to them here's the secret to
a great suit fit matters more than
anything and the only way to get a suit
that fits right is to get it custom in
the past that has been unbelievably
expensive but endo Chino allows you to
make a fully custom suit for a
ridiculous price often less than four
hundred dollars I don't know how they do
it but they're soos use the best
materials and our perfectly tailored I
will never get an off-the-rack suit
again I've had trouble with
made-to-measure suits in the past
because I couldn't get the measurements
right
but with endo Chino I just walked into
the store and got the full attention of
a stylist for over an hour
what's up Andrew he took my measurements
and a couple weeks later I got the best
fitting suit of my entire life it was
perfect right out of the box legal
eagles can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 379 when you enter the
promo code legal eagle at checkout or
use the link in the description clicking
the link really helps out this channel
that's Indochina Calm promo code legal
eagle for the best custom suit of your
entire life could you fall in your place
is somebody else's Pablos so do you
agree leave your objections in the
comments and check out my other real
lawyer reactions over here where I will
see you in court